إنها رائحة كريهة وربما تكون ضارة
بعرض قارة الولايات المتحدة. كتلة كبيرة
من الأعشاب البحرية تتحرك 13 مليون طن،
وهذا كثير من الطحالب، وحتى لو
وصل بعض منها إلى الشاطئ على شواطئ
المكسيك أو فلوريدا، فسوف يعيث
فسادًا في السياحة، وهو ما يسمى بالسخرية.
يمكن أن تكون مجموعة بلوم التي تحدث بشكل طبيعي من الأعشاب البحرية هذا العام هي الأكبر على الإطلاق
وتمتد بشكل جماعي لمسافة تزيد عن
5000 ميل من شواطئ إفريقيا إلى
خليج المكسيك، ومن
المتوقع أن تندفع ما يسمى بالفقاعة عبر منطقة البحر الكاريبي وحتى
خليج المكسيك.  خلال
فصل الصيف ومن المتوقع أن يكون في
فلوريدا في شهر يوليو تقريبًا يمكن أن يكون السخرية
خطيرًا على البشر ولهذا السبب
يقول الخبراء إن تنظيف الشواطئ يجب أن يتم
بحذر، فهو يطلق
كبريتيد الهيدروجين وهو غاز سام لا تريد
أن تعرف أنه يتنفس
خاصة عندما  إنها
بتركيزات عالية والمناطق المغلقة تقول
مع رياح منخفضة كما أنها تحتوي على الكثير من
الزرنيخ في الأنسجة إذا سافرت إلى
منطقة بها السرجس كما يقول المسؤولون
للإشراف على الأطفال تجنب لمس الأعشاب البحرية أو
السباحة بالقرب منها واستخدم القفازات إذا كان
يجب عليك التعامل معها  إذا كان لديك
تهيج أو مشاكل في التنفس حول
كبريتيد الهيدروجين، فابق بعيدًا عن
الشاطئ وتجنب أو قلل من وقتك على
الشاطئ إذا كنت تعاني من الربو أو
مشاكل تنفسية أخرى من أجل الصحة،
أنا ماندي جايثر